in an interview released today with
fantastic podcaster Marc Maron President
Obama addressed the persistence of
racism in America in an unusually blunt
way in doing so he referred to a word
that has been basically vanished from
respectful conversation and in the quiet
in doing so he ginned up myriad
sensationalized headlines and a bit of a
media conniption so let's take a listen
to the cause of this controversy and its
full context the legacy of slavery Jim
Crow discrimination in almost every
institution of our lives you know that
it casts a long shadow and that's still
part of our DNA that's that's passed on
it we're not cured of it racism racism
we are not cured of clearly and-and-and
it's not just a matter of it not being
polite to say [ __ ] in public that's
not the measure of whether racism still
exists or not it's not just a matter of
overt discrimination we have societies
don't overnight completely erase
everything that happened two to three
hundred years prior so mark was the
president right or wrong to invoke that
rather loaded term and should the media
plate or bleep it out it's uncomfortable
in both instances the original remarks
and the media's decision I think the
President did in a conversational way
clearly to make a point and I think
while it's a tough call for the media I
think people should do what we did we
just to play it the president United
States said it that's good enough for me
it's good enough for history but there
is a there's a distinction
not to get too academic here but
linguists will tell you there's the
distinction between using a word and
invoking a word mentioning a word
referring to a word he is using the word
to make a point he's not just using it
right that's important and I think it
there's a we there's a there's so much
euphemism around both profanity and this
kind of profanity I like that the
president's not being euphemistic I like
that he's using it in instructional way
and I think the press is ridiculous when
it when it has F star star K well every
time you see that you know exactly what
that is or n star star star R we know
what those things are the mind go
to it immediately so the purpose of
bleeping it out or showing it in that
kind of baburaj way doesn't actually
accomplish its purpose anyway I don't
think it's always ridiculous I do think
in this case everybody's right to play
it and to show it and to have the
conversation and it's so good the
president's going down there on Friday
because South Carolina and the country
still need more unity around race
absolutely